I'm gonna be a pilot the best in the
galaxy heard about a job big shot
gangster putting together crew who these
guns console Lindo parachute oh is that
a wookie may 25th
if you come with us
you're in this life for good
un
that's just solo the Star Wars story
rated pg-13
[Music]
[Music]
you're after something
[Music]
is it revenge
money
or is it something else you look good
little rough around the edges but good
heard about a job big shot gangster
putting together crew
I'm a driver and I'm a flier
the ladies a long time for a shot like
this
what do you think well what do you know
you got a land on the ship yeah no guy
either by smuggler around I heard a
story about you I was wondering if it's
true everything you read about me it's
true l-3 let's go to mean man's face who
are these guys
if you come with us you're in this life
for good might wanna buckle up baby
[Music]
let me give you some advice assume
everyone will betray you
and you'll never be disappointed I got a
really good feeling about this
when do you know how to fly a hundred
and ninety years old good great
[Music]
[Music]
you